foreign
[Music]
wait
I should warn you before you step inside
the house this could change the course
of your entire life I'm not afraid of a
couple goes
you say that now
[Music]
this Mansion is unhinged
these ghosts definitely don't want to
leave
clerks around every corner
God give us a break there's so many bad
people in the world haunt them amen
I do like surprises is anybody else seen
this
we're gonna fight whether we like it or
not or else was stuck here for eternity
if this comes down to an exorcism or a
big trouble
more
my friend was mugged he was tall yet
hair that was sticking out of a what a
top hat Top Hat yes yeah yeah it's like
Top Hat you would pull a rabbit out of
it probably uh eyes they were a bit uh
like a raccoon they sit back
and he was smiling like yeah like that
exactly is this the man who mugged you
wow you just did that just now
[Music]